la quinzaine du commerce équitable ça se
passe aussi en bas de chez vous sur
toute la côte d'azur on en parle avec la
coprésidente d'artisans du monde dans
les alpes-maritimes je vienne le gué
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
cette année vous avez décidé de mettre
un visage sur votre action avec la venue
dans producteurs péruvien c'est ça qui a
fait le déplacement
donc nous allons faire venir un
producteur péruvien qui s'appelle javier
et rodriguez et qui va venir témoigner
de ce que le commerce équitable rapporte
à sa coopérative qui fait travailler
deux mille personnes qu'est ce que ça a
changé justement pour ces deux mille
personnes alors ça a changé leur
situation sociale et économique ils sont
mieux payés et puis aussi ils peuvent
construire des logements sociaux side et
des écoles
voilà tout ce qui est autour du social
et de l'environnement aussi parce que la
protection de l'environnement dans la
charge du commerce équitable
alors c'est vrai que quand on parle de
commerce équitable on pense à au bout du
monde en fait
est-ce que c'est pas à contre-courant de
la nouvelle tendance écologique qui nous
dit consommer près de chez vous oui bien
sûr mais de toute façon est ce qu'on va
se passer du café est ce qu'on va se
passer du thé est ce qu'on va se passer
du cacao
alors donc de toutes façons si vous
achetez tous ces produits là autant les
acheter au commerce équitable
après si on s'en passe là mais pour
l'instant tout le monde en tout cas on
en consomme donc il vaut mieux acheter
au commerce équitable qui paye mais les
petits producteurs qui laurent qui
laurent la dignité qui leur ouvrent
leurs besoins vitaux de parce qu'on leur
donne et de commerce équitable près de
chez nous avec les petits producteurs
locaux vous vous en occuper aussi nous
sommes très présents nous faisons partie
du collectif sur du collectif sur la
préservation des terres agricoles dans
le département
parce que nous sommes très proches des
amap aussi l'association pour le
maintien d'une agriculture paysanne
parce que chez nous aussi les petits les
petits paysans sont pauvres y en a
beaucoup qui se suicident d'ailleurs et
donc nous sommes un soutien à l'heure à
leurs revendications
depuis dix ans que cette quinzaine
existe le commerce équitable s'est
démocratisée on le retrouve maintenant
en grande surface on a vu l'exemple dans
le reportage sur malongo et pourtant
vous n'êtes pas franchement pour le
développement du commerce équitable en
grande surface c'est à dire que ya cinq
ans dans l'association artisans du monde
nous avons pris position contre ça fait
que nos produits de nos centrales
d'achats solidaires mende ne sont pas en
grande surface
par contre ça vous dérange parce que ça
rend ses produits plus accessibles
ça nous dérange parce que c'est un non
sens parce que c'est pas une filière
intégrée c'est-à-dire que nous on fait
du commerce équitable du début jusqu'à
la fin sauf le transport pour l'instant
mais dans ces grandes surfaces
que je sache les employés sont quand
même exploit était exploité donc on veut
pas parler de commercialité quand
quelqu'un dans la chaîne et exploiter
mais quand même on reconnaît depuis cinq
ou six ans le commerce équitable rentrer
en grande surface que ça a permis le
développement et la connaissance du
commerce équitable auprès des gens comme
geneviève le guet
merci pour toutes les précisions et tout
le programme de la quinzaine sur votre
site internet www.aaquebec.org
[Musique]